on a warm summer evening in livin these
people have come to hear from the
far-right afd the speaker is andreas
calpads
the party's lead candidate in
Brandenburg and according to German
media a man linked to neo-nazi groups he
denies some but not all of the claims
the AFD is popular in several areas of
this state where unemployment remains
higher than the national average and
towns like Lubin have an aging
population although the immigrant
population here is tiny
Calvin sees message is uncompromising we
demand criminal so-called refugees who
can be deported must first be imprisoned
one thing is clear
integration means you adapt to the
country it does not mean the country
adapts to you the AFD s closest rival is
the governing social democrat party
whose votes share has been shrinking for
years when silent in our state needs
reliability cohesion and strong
leadership I stand for that let's stand
together to make sure our land stays in
good hands in the future polls show the
race in Brandenburg is very close
perhaps nowhere more so than here sure
and I hereby bare lean a leafy commuter
town of over 12,000 people in Mays
European elections the top five parties
were separated by less than 2% of the
votes
which explains why national party
leaders have come to press the flesh the
Green Party's anna-lena bear Bach being
the latest to push for votes democracy
survives and people talking to one
another they argue and think wait maybe
the other person is also right and they
say yes when energy is great I'm
concerned about the health consequences
I would like to believe people go home
and think about how we can address these
problems together and then there is the
left party whose political ancestors ran
the old communist East Germany and
who've governed here with the Social
Democrats for the past 10 years they
hope their call for solidarity will
energize the electorate and for them
like all the other parties
the key to winning this state lies in
winning places like this
Dominic Kane aljazeera in Brandenburg